hello everybody and welcome back to the
second part of our live program in which
our customers and collaborators are
sharing their experience
around our own combined solution for
clinical research testing
so it is my pleasure now to introduce uh
two more speakers for this session we
will have uh
dr craig mcinton who is director at the
genomic diagnostic and bioinformatics
unit
he's also professor of the department of
pathology at the university of alabama
burning up
he will be talking about utilizing the
genexis system
to detect complex genetic variants in
human tissue spacemen
and right after this first talk we will
have another one from dr j bayani
she's principal investigator scientist
at the ontario institute for cancer
research
and she will be talking about the
evaluation of the uncle mind
comprehensive class
essay for profiling of solid tumors
so thank you both the speakers for
participating in this event
right after those presentation we will
have a q a session where where the
audience will be
in the position of asking questions to
the speakers
with no further delay now i would like
to leave the stage
to craig please go ahead with your
presentation thank you everybody for
joining
okay hi everyone my name is craig
mckinnon i'm from the
university of alabama at birmingham
here are some disclosures for today's
talk
okay so today i'm going to talk about
the genexis system
and go over the motivation that we at
uab
head for transitioning over to the
genexis and then talk about some
research cases that we ran
on the genexis when we're evaluating it
and then i'm going to finish
up with an interesting case describing a
mutation and a human lung cancer
specimen
so in a molecular oncology research lab
there's a couple of considerations you
have to take into
you have to evaluate when you're setting
up a panel one is the targets
target genes of interest for your panel
you need to
a lab needs to be able to detect a wide
range of genetic variants
this includes single nucleotide variants
insertion deletions
fusions and copy number of variations
and as we all know
some of these variants are hard to
detect in addition
a a platform that you are going to use
in your lab also should be capable of
testing
a wide range of specimens oftentimes the
specimens that are in your
biobanks or that you're working with are
very small they can be very poor quality
oftentimes coming from ffpe in which the
dna or rna is degraded the source can be
a needle biopsy a cytology specimen
cell free dna and ffvp
samples so you want to find a platform
that is really good
at handling a wide range of specimens at
some
depending on what test you're using a
lot of times your
sample isn't good enough and you might
end up rejecting
five to twenty percent of your samples
um
so given this uh it's important to have
a
um an asset that can have a lot of
specimens
so you can think about really three
different tiers of testing
uh oftentimes you might have a specimen
that's really tiny
you might only be able to do either a
single ihc test or maybe even just
evaluate one gene
such as like k ras or in ras or egfr
or if your specimen is small but
suitable for doing a panel
you might have to limit the number of
genes you can have on your panel and it
can be a combination of dna and rna
targets
allowing you to look for variants like
insertion deletions or single nucleotide
variants in the dna
or fusions with using rna or if you're
lucky enough to have a
large specimen you can do a
comprehensive panel that can include
hundreds of genes
and do the whole spectrum of mutations
including
single nucleotide variants insertion
deletions fusions and copy number
changes
at uab we had historically used a
haloplex target enrichment assay that
had a fairly high
requirement for our starting dna input
the the kit required 200 nanograms but
we had
optimized it down to 100 nanograms and
the assay did have one advantage is that
each molecule that you sequenced had a
unique molecular barcode which is
important
for being able to have high accuracy and
quality of your sequencing data
but one of the problems with this assay
was that the starting material was so
high that oftentimes we were unable to
sequence a lot of our
research samples so that was one of the
main reasons that started to
ask motivate us to look around for
another system
and we evaluated the ion torrent genexis
and it had some
features and qualities that were really
important to us one is it could work
with a wide range of tissue samples
most of our samples research samples are
ffpe
and we have a lot of blood from those
same
samples that are paired with it it works
really well with low input
dna and rna each pool that you work with
only needs 10 nanograms
it can detect depending on the on the
kit or assay you're using it can detect
a wide range of variants
including smvs indels cnvs and fusions
has very little hands-on time which is
really nice for uh for the lab
and the two features that uh really were
most uh
important to us were the fast turnaround
time of two days
and then we did some calculations and
recognized that it represented a massive
cost savings for us
um this next slide goes over our cost
savings
uh it's you see this table here and this
is an evaluation of
running uh our current panel
which is a hundred gene uh dna panel
compared to running the oncomine
comprehensive assay version three
it's a research panel that includes 163
genes
on the genexis and by doing a comparison
of the two assays we recognize that it
would be close to 300
000 a year in cost savings um
which basically would be close to paying
for the instrument within one year
in addition to the to the huge cost
savings we also got
a lot of new assays coming out of the
genexis we could do
uh rna this uh which will replace some
of our fish assays which are very
expensive to run
and less sensitive and the faster
turnaround time
of two days was very very compelling
and it also allowed us to capture a lot
of the small specimens we weren't
normally able to sequence
so during our evaluation of the ion
torrent
genexis system we looked at two of the
assays that are available the oncoming
myeloid assay
which targets 40 dna targets and 29 rna
fusion genes
and the oncoming precision assay we
found some of our old reference samples
we had previously sequenced
uh we found four specimens we wanted to
resequence
that were dna derived from blood and
three samples that were derived from
ffpe that we were going to run on the
oncoming precision assay
so for them we'll talk about the myeloid
genexis assay first
so we identified samples that had
10 mutations in 10 genes that were very
important
in different myeloid disorders and these
genes could be
categorized into different types of
pathways in the cell that are important
for cell growth
uh you're also very prevalent in
different diseases that
um affect the blood including myeloid
leukemias and myeloproliferative
diseases
and these some of these genes uh
represented variants
that were really hard to detect too
either due to the size of the variant
such as in flit 3 or calr or ones that
were just notoriously difficult to
sequence because of the
gene itself might have had a lot of gc
rich content such as with cebpa
so we thought by selecting these genes
it would really give us a
a good chance to evaluate the system and
see how well it performs
so of the four samples we had
each sample had between one
to four or five mutations in it we ran
each sample and duplicate
and so this table shows the
two of the samples the second column
shows the
mutation the genes that we were um
targeting
uh with the mutations listed and some of
the metrics from the
sequencing run are described and the
next slide
are other two samples that had mutations
in cal r
or a large set of genes and
again the sequencing metrics shown here
and so
this slide shows the results of running
these same samples
on a confirmation assay which is the
gene studio which is a different
platform
it runs the same genes but in a
different assay
and it's just compare how well
the genexis assay does to the gene
studio assay
so all the data here is summarized on
this slide and we can see for our four
samples we had an excellent concordance
everything that we expected to be
detected was detected
on both the genexis and the gene studio
a couple of points to make out here is
on sample two
we had two variants two genes that had
variants the dnm
t3a and the wt1 our assay at uab
detected variants of these two genes are
not covered by the genexis or the
gene studio assays so we did not detect
them but
we weren't expecting to detect them and
then one of our samples
sample four included a jack ii mutation
at a very low
variant allele frequency around three
percent and when we ran it in duplicate
on the genexis and on the gene studio
only one of the two samples were we able
to detect the jack
ii mutation and we attributed this to
the very low uh very allele frequency
so in summary uh comparing the genexis
to our in-house assay
all the variants uh were detected as
expected
and we had 100 concordance uh between
the two platforms the genexis and the
gene studio 5.
so we're very happy by this performance
so now we'll talk about
the oncoming precision assay we ran
three samples through
using the oncoming precision assay to
look at a
range of different variants the first
sample
we'll talk about is a case that had an
amplification of the egfr
gene now egfr is overexpressed
in a type of brain tumor called a
glioblastoma
and that's important signaling pathway
that is believed to drive growth of the
brain tumors
so we had a sample in which we had
identified egfr amplification
we ran it in duplicate and this chart
shows that on the genexis we were able
to pick up egfr amplification
and recognize that about in each of the
samples are roughly 33
copy number amplification of the egfr
gene
now another interesting thing that came
out of this experiment is we
recognized that the same sample also had
a loss of
an allele of the cdk n2a gene
which we did not know because our assay
at uab did not target this
so in the sample there was a gain of
egfr
and loss of cdkn2a
another variant we were interested in
involves the met gene
now the diagram on the right side
shows uh in the upper part of the
diagram what happens
normally to the met gene and that's
exons 13 and 14 and 15 are normally
spliced together
and then the protein after it's
translated gets inserted to
the membrane and the levels of the met
gene are tightly controlled
because in exon 14 there's a recognition
site for the cbl
degradation system and when met levels
reach a certain level
the cbl system comes along and degrades
the met gene
product and that's how the cell
maintains
the appropriate levels of the met gene
and can control ceiling that way
now in certain tumors including lung
cancer met
exon 14 is deleted and that leads to
exon 13 being spliced adjacent to exon
15.
the consequence of this is that the cbl
recognition site is now deleted and that
leads to accumulation of met
in the membrane and increased net
signaling which
promotes cell growth so
in order to detect this event
you can take two strategies at uab we
sequence the dna
and when you do this you have to examine
both the splice acceptor and splice
donor site of the mexon met exon 14
as well as the dry sequence which is the
recognition sequence for the cbl
degradation pathway
so there's a lot of real estate that you
have to target and sometimes you miss
the mutation due to the sequencing
issues but we had a sample where we did
find the splice site
mutation and in order to compare this
we would predict that due to the splice
site mutation
the exon 14 would not be in the
transcript
so from the same specimen we isolated
rna
sequenced it on the genexis and
identified
that indeed met exon 14 was deleted in
the specimen
and that's shown in the lower lower
table where you can see
in the column that says gene exons met
exon 13
is fused directly to net exon 15. so
it's a way to confirm
that both at the dna level and the rna
level
the mutation leads to loss of net exon
14.
now i'd like to finish this talk
by describing a really interesting
research case we had
of us of a of a sample
that had uh bilateral lung cancer
uh on in each lung the right lung and
the left lung
and when we sequenced uh both of these
uh
lung tumors from the same uh from the
same
uh patient we saw that on the right lung
there was a activating mutation in the
egfr
gene uh it's uh changes the
glycine at position seven one nine seven
one nine to an alanine
and in this specimen the variant allele
frequency for
this uh mutation was 12.75
we're really interested to also see that
this
this specimen also had a t790m mutation
at 6.2 percent variant allele frequency
this is really unusual because
t-790m you usually see that in the
context of a
lung cancer specimen that had been
previously treated
with drugs that target the egfr pathway
so when we sequence the contralateral
lung
we found a different egfr activating
mutation the l85ar
mutation at six point eight percent
allele frequency
and again the same t-790 mu
m mutation at around the same variant
level frequency so this is really
unusual and we wanted to explore it
further
and so something right off the bat
you're starting to think this is unusual
and it looks like this could be a
germline t790m mutation
and in fact when t790m
is first identified in treat
pre-treatment specimens such as the ones
i just described
about 50 percent of time this is a
germline mutation
and these tumors often have a
secondary egfr activating mutation and
the degree of
risk and penetrance for develop
developing a clinical
non-small cell lung cancer syndrome is
unclear in these types of specimens
the behavior of these mutations is
unknown there's not many patients who've
been described to that some reports
say that this is an indolent clinical
course but that's not always the rule
and they often are associated with
having multiple lungs tumors
in both lungs which is what we saw in
our in this case
on the sample so this is rev uh
summarizing a review article
that looked at germline egfr mutations
described 14 different mutations
affecting egfr
and six of them uh had the t 790m
mutation as we saw in our samples
and it's interesting that in five of
these six samples
there was a secondary egfr mutation that
was also described
um similar to what we've seen so we
really want to
investigate this further to confirm that
this was a germline t790m
variant so we resequenced the tumor dna
on the genexis
using the oncoming precision assay
okay and so with the two
specimens one from the right lung and
one from the left lung we were able to
isolate dna
only from the right lung unfortunately
the left lung specimen we had
it was depleted and there's no more
opportunity to
extract dna so if we're focusing just on
the right lung
we expect to see the t790m mutation
as well as the g719a mutation
okay so we sequenced on the genexis and
this slide gives you an overview of the
run level metrics that come off
of the sequencer that allow you to
assess how
well the sequencing run worked uh this
diagram on the right side of the slide
that shows a heat map of your lane
you can see it's red which means that
the the
the lane loaded really well uh
the top left shows that your loading
efficiency was 87 percent
it was about 1.5 uh giga giga bases
of total uh sequence each sequencing
reads about 100 nucleotides long so you
had 14 million
800 000 reads and overall the the run
looked really
good so this is a nice way to assess
your run um
before you start doing your analysis in
addition to run level metrics
uh you can for each sample look at the
sample level metrics
and that's summarized on this slide and
in this specimen this one
particular sample that we're looking at
there is 1.4 million mapped reads
the mean read length of those 97 base
pairs and we had 98.4
uniformity so these are very good
metrics
uh based on that you have confidence
that when you look at the
readout from the of the variants that
are detected in your specimen
you have high confidence that they're
accurate so this
right lung specimen that had the t7idm
and the g719a
mutations we see here that they both
that they have uh instead of having five
percent variant in their frequencies
around 50
so right now we know that there was
something wrong with our assay when we
ran it that we were missing a lot of
these mutant reads
and it was interesting to us that this
patient also had a known polymorphism at
the exact same variant allele frequency
that's the q787q
which is just nine nucleotides away from
t790m
so we looked at the pileup of these two
variants
and we can see that they're insist with
each other so that means that every read
at which we detect the t790m variant
also had the polymorphic
variant q797q which is a silent
mutation it's not a mutations of
polymorphism due to single
nucleotide change on the genexis the
variant allele frequency for these two
were identical
whereas in the uab the 790 m
variant allele frequency was only six
percent so clearly we missed
a large fraction of the mutant alleles
so this shows us that the t-790m
was a germline variant and we confirmed
this
by sequencing the blood that was paired
with these specimens
and it also had a 50 approximately 50
variant allele frequency
uh reviewing the literature there's a
paper we we discovered
uh published in 2007 that showed that
when you sequence
uh egfr variants using cell-free dna
germline variants have a very allele
frequency around 50 percent
which is shown by those green dots on
the right
bar graph whereas somatic variants
which are depicted by the gray dots have
a much lower variant allele frequency
so the findings from this case is that
where all the expected variants
were detected by the oncoming precision
assay
and it confirmed the t-790m
variant that we identified was germline
origin
the q787 variant was not
specifically covered by the opa a assay
the oncoming precision essay
but these variants were covered by
amplicons that are contained in the opa
so by modifying the bed file we were
able to call these variants
and confirm that both the q7a
787q polymorphism and the t790m
variant that we had initially detected
both had a very allele frequency of 50
they were visualized on the same read
and it confirmed the germline origin of
this variant
so in summary we looked at four
dna samples derived from blood and two
dna samples derived from
ffpe research specimens and one rna
that was isolated from ffpe these were
all running duplicate on the genexis
we had 100 concordance between the
genexis opa
which is the oncoming precision assay
and the genexis myeloid assay
with the uab in-house haloplex assay
additional variants were identified for
example we detected copy number
variation
of egfr and and which was an
amplification
and copy number variation of the
gene which was a deletion the
sensitivity of genexis assay was
superior for some of our targeted
regions
for example the t790m and we gained
significant efficiency
with turnaround time hands-on time and
reagent costs
so that's all for this presentation and
if you have any questions i look forward
to
discussing them with you okay so thank
you very much
uh thanks very much for inviting me to
share with you some of our experiences
in the evaluation of the oncoming
comprehensive assay
plus for profiling of solid tumor
samples
are my disclosures
so the results of many uh translational
research
initiatives have been the identified
identification of a number of
prognostic and predictive biomarker and
this is really in response
as i said to the translational research
and drug development
so what is it that we need in terms of
future precision oncology
it's a delicate balance in obtaining
essays that have
rapid workflows robust informatics and
reporting
updated content and links to the
the literature and public databases but
we also have to be mindful of the fact
that the samples that we're profiling
are getting smaller and smaller
some of the quality of these samples can
be quite poor
we also need to think about the context
of some of these
tissues so thinking about things like
humor to normal content
and once again the uniformity in in the
informatic workflow
not too long ago we were in search of an
ngs based
platform that could help harmonize some
of the
biomarker signatures that we developed
both through
genomics and transcriptomics and we came
across
the oncoming family of profiling
solutions and we asked the questions
whether the oncoming platform could
really satisfy our translational
research needs
but before i go into the evaluation of
this
uh platform i wanted to give you the
context in which we were searching for
this
so a lot of my work at the oicr focuses
around improving the clinical management
of women with breast cancer specifically
in the early hormone receptor positive
breast cancer setting so a little bit of
the background
approximately one in eight women and
much rarer in men but about
one in eight hundred men will develop
breast cancer in their lifetime
approximately fifteen percent a percent
will die from their disease
and approximately eighty percent of the
breast cancers that are seen in the
clinic
are hormone receptor positive
unfortunately despite adequate initial
responses to that anti-integrin therapy
approximately fifteen
fifty percent will experience a
recurrence
we had previously identified a 95 gene
transcriptomic
prognostic race signature in a cohort of
almost
3 000 patients and what we found that
there were a population of women
who are at higher risk for occurrence
following an anti-therapy
the genes that comprise this signature
were related to things like cell cycle
dna damage and many of these pathways
are currently being targeted
by therapies being used in the treatment
cancer
we know that transcriptomics is only one
part
of understanding the biology of these
cancers and we also have to integrate
things like
poppy number as well as mutational so in
a separate study we use a subset
of that cohort to look at the copy
number and mutational changes
uh in genes and key signaling pathways
again related to
targeted therapies that are being used
currently to treat breast cancer
and we found that the alterations in
pathways
also found to be prognostic
so to improve the clinical management of
breast cancers in the
earlier even the neoadjuvant setting we
need more informative prognostic
biomarkers for risk on anti-therapy
but we also need predictive biomarkers
for the rational stratification
to targeted therapies again we want to
be able to best match the therapy to the
biology
cancer we believe that we have a
comprehensive transfer atomic as well as
genomic signature
that can answer this clinical need so
what we need now
is a platform we can integrate these
biomarkers
into one platform and one workflow
it helps stratify these women not only
for risk
but to specific targeted therapies
another cancer that has a clear clinical
need is pancreatic cancer
although much rarer than breast cancer
one in 64 people will be diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer
and as you can see by the estimated
five-year survival the outcome for these
patients is quite poor
the treatment includes surgery
chemotherapy radiation therapy and in
some cases in the context of clinical
trial
there might be biomarker directed
therapies
the challenges for pancreatic cancer is
slightly different than
breast cancer although biopsy material
is being profiled these cancers have
poor tumor cellularity
and unfortunately there's a challenge of
the poor outcome in survival
times facing these patients
the oicr has invested in a large
pancreatic cancer initiative called
pancurx
and the goal of this was to profile the
genomic and transcriptomic landscape of
pancreatic cancer
what i'm showing here are the results
from uh publication
about two years ago from the first 60
odd patients
where fresh frozen tissues from needle
core biopsies
were enriched through laser capture
microdissection
and extracted for whole genome and
transcriptomic profiling
the median turnover from the time of
biopsy through to the sequencing results
was
about 35 days and it required anywhere
from 50
to 100 nanograms of extracted dna and
rna
as well as a match a normal for patient
i've shown here the average coverage for
the tumor as well as
the normal dna
so to improve the clinical management of
pancreatic cancers
we need to identify uh additional
prognostic and predictive biomarkers
and the pancreax encompass trial
initiative will help
elucidate some of these key a prognostic
and predictive biomarkers
but what we also need now is a rapid and
robust targeted assay
and a requirement for minimal nucleic
acid input
so this brings us to the oncoming
comprehensive assay
and what our translational research
needs are and here i've shown
uh some of the the overview of content
for the oncoming comprehensive asset
plus
and the workflow of about three to five
days from the time of sample prep
through to sequencing and through
analysis so what we're looking for in an
assay is something that is robust and
reproducible
has a streamlined workflow rapid
turnaround time
requires low input of nucleic acid and
is amenable to nucleic acids that are
extracted from
formula and fixed paraffin-embedded
tissues we also need
a workflow that has top quality
informatics and
reporting of the relevant uh variants
as well as up to date and clinically
relevant content
so one of the first things we did when
we uh looked at
whether the oncoming comprehensive assay
or the oncoming product
line could satisfy our our research
needs we did a reproducibility study
and for that we extracted dna from about
33
hormone fixed paraffin embedded in this
case breast cancer tissue
the dna was extracted and that same
aliquot of dna
was processed in two different oratories
and as you can see here these are the
metrics from both sides site a and site
b
of the the general qcs that come
from running the assay when we looked
at the concordance between the variant
detection and copy number detection
and these are based on the default
oncoming
settings we see that there was excellent
concordance on those
bearing calls between the two sites and
over 95 percent concordance on copy
number calls and as you can see here
in one site the bracket to
copy number loss was not detected but
when we looked at that data you can see
that
the copy number was just outside the
established threshold
threshold for the assay so again we were
really happy
with these initial results
we then wanted to look at the
performance of the oncoming
comprehensive assay to other
technologies and this is because we're
mindful
of the fact that the data that we've
generated across many of our
uh projects have been derived from
different platforms and different
technologies
so when we wanted to look at the
concordance between copy number we had
orthogonal data for some of these
samples
based on alphametrics oncoscan as well
as mlpa and these
represent some comparable bulk nucleic
acid technologies
we also had orthogonal data in about 17
cases
based on fish and when we look at the
concordance and again
uh excellent concordance between the
asymmetric
scan and mlpa data and not unexpectedly
variable concordance based on the
in-situ or the purcell
technology when considering
variant detection in a subset of samples
we had
pic3 ca mutation information
based on the mass spec based uh assay
sequino
and again versus ocav3 and when we use
either one of the benchmarks we found
that we had
a 98 concordance for the detection of
pic3ca mutations
across these samples
so not too long ago uh probably about 10
months ago
uh thermo fisher released this newest uh
kid on the block which is the oca plus
assay so once again we wanted to look at
the
performance between its predecessor
ocav3
and here we have the same samples that
were run by ocav3
and these are fresh frozen samples
compared to those run
against the oca plus assay and again
you can see here in our hands we are
achieving
uh the minimal requirements uh for
cutoffs for the different qcs
for both the assays and again comparable
results
between the between the two essays
and when we look at the concordance for
copy number as well as actual mutations
and again this is off of the default
settings
we see that puppy number and actual
mutations
found in ocav3 were also identified in
oca plus
at similar variant of the efficiencies
or copy numbers
and what about ffpe dna
these are the results from about 66
breast cancers that were profiled both
on ocav3 and oca plus
once again we see comparable results in
terms of the
accused metrics for the sequencing and
again in our hands we are
exceeding the minimum requirements for a
successful run
for these assays
and what the results look like in terms
of copy number and actionable mutations
once again we see excellent concordance
between
variants that were detected again
overlapping genes between ocav3
and oca plus and in fact there is
improved uh germline filtering
in the oca plus and we were able to
filter out some
uh variants that were detected in ocav3
that
um that were passing the filter and
again all copy number changes and
and mutations uh detected in both assays
exist uh at the same similar copy number
as well as variantal frequencies
one of the outputs for ocav3 and oca
plus
are whole genome plots and what i'm
showing you here again are the same
samples one processed by ocav3 and one
by the plus assay
and you can see the extra content in the
oca plus
gives a really good whole genome
information again giving us information
about the karyotypic complexity of these
cancers
we also have aphametric oncoscan whole
genome sniper ray data and again this is
the same case
and we see that the uncle mine plus
profile gives a readout similar to what
you would find using the whole genome
array my understanding is that in
a new release of the analysis workflow
oca plus will be able to deliver
additional information
including loh so we're looking forward
to that feature in the coming months
and again how does it compare to whole
genome sequencing so this is
again the same case uh processed by
whole
genome sequencing and the copy number
profile generated
compared to ocs and we see a similar
patterns of puppy number gains and
losses
across this cancer gene
we then looked at the concordance in key
driver genes and this is based on the
pancreatic
initial pancreatic data again whole
genome sequencing versus oca
plus and again we're really happy to see
that we're seeing over 90 95
concordance in terms of poppy number as
well as concordance on the key driver
variants
relevant to pancreatic cancer and i
remind you that
uh the depth of coverage for the whole
genome sequencing
is on average of 50x
and again just to summarize our oca plus
experience to date in archival tissues
but we've now processed uh since the
release of this assay 231
early hormone receptor positive breast
cancer and these are
dnas that have been extracted over five
to six years ago
from blocks that are originally
processed over 10 years ago
from this sample set 19 samples have
been excluded from further analysis
and again we followed the general qc
metrics and
you know those cases that had greater
than two qc metrics failing or falling
below the manufacturer's suggested costs
were excluded
and we already excluded some of those
samples
due to poor library qcs and again this
is suggesting that we just had poor
quality dna
in about 23 samples uh they
failed one of the or fell below uh one
of the
uh qc metrics suggesting that we might
require a manual curation
of the variance but overall we're really
happy with our sequencing success rate
of about 90 percent and again here are
some of the
qcs from these 231 samples
so the question is where are we going
with this we're currently
preparing a manuscript
detailing a study where we performed
ocav3
in 387 or early hormone positive
early hormone receptor positive breast
cancer
and the results here have shown that
some of the copy number and mutational
changes linked to signaling pathways
are prognostic the goal then is to
validate
the rest of the cohort which is about 3
000
patients from this retrospective
clinical
trial using the oca plus platform
so we go back to our question does the
oncoming platform satisfy our
translational research needs
is the assay robust and reproducible
we've demonstrated that the same sample
process at different site
using the manufacturer's suggested
protocols yields the same results
is the workflow streamlined and does it
offer rapid turnaround time
we've shown that the time to extraction
sequencing analysis could be achieved in
as little as three to five days
we've also shown that you only need 10
nanograms of
input per pool so an average of 20
nanograms per assay
and this is in comparison to some other
assays that require upwards of 50
nanograms
we've also demonstrated that the assay
is amenable to nucleic acids
extracted from formula and fixed
paraffin embedded tissue
well i wasn't able to share with you
some of the data from our other studies
but we have been able to rescue um
samples that failed
other sequencing technologies by using
the oncoming platform
and be able and were able to generate
good data
from those poor degraded samples
is there top quality informatics and
reporting of relevant variants
so we found that the varying calling for
this assay
is a robust and the software does
provide flexibility to the user so that
you can define
your filters for a more customized
approach
to be able to answer the translational
research questions
for your study one of the key things
that
was of interest to us is that varying
calling is not dependent
on a match patient normal
the next factor is their up-to-date and
clinically relevant content
so the current version of the oncoming
comprehensive assay plus represents
expanded gene content
and signatures that are relevant to the
current pan-cancer precision oncology
research setting
and and this has been determined by that
academic clinical oncology
and and pharmaceutical uh key opinion
leaders and
and we have been uh really lucky to have
been working with thermal fisher
and be able to uh provide input on the
current content
although i didn't talk about um the
oncoming knowledge based reporter
uh in this um session um this this
module is uh updated used to be updated
quarterly but i understand now that is
updated monthly
so again this is a wonderful resource
uh that you can use uh in conjunction
with the results that come out from this
assay
and currently is this technology uh
available and widely used well
the ion torrent instrumentation is
widely used and is
available for rapid uptake of new
validated tests
in the last few minutes i'd like to
share with you how we're moving
all of this translational work forward
about a year and a half ago we were
awarded a genome canada
genomic applications partnership program
grant and this brings together
an academic as well as a commercial
partner to bring genomic solutions to
market
what i've shared with you today are some
of the clinical needs in some key areas
particularly in pancreatic cancer breast
cancer and while i didn't talk about it
today we have identified
a signature that can identify occult
high-grade cancer in
prostate biopsy samples the deliverables
are to bring an integrated ngs approach
for each of these cancers and to be able
to validate
these signatures as well as validating
the platform
to be easily disseminated to other
translational research partners working
in this space
so finally i'd like to acknowledge all
our collaborators and members of our
team
for the work that i've shown here today
thank you very much
all right thank you very much to both
speakers
once again for their excellent
presentation appreciate them a lot
and we're now moving forward with the q
a session
we have a couple questions coming from
the audience
um we'll actually start with uh first
with a question uh
to craig uh again thank you for your
presentation it was uh extremely
hands-on so very useful very practical
appreciate a lot and uh the quiz the
first question
um it's about your you build a business
case about the number of hours and
you know the time that you save when
using the genexis
now would you say that this is something
unique or there
people could actually replicate that
kind of business case
and use it in in their own setting
honest because you have a special
setting in your lab
um that's a good question
i think the approach we took is
easily translatable to any um situation
because um the uh there's nothing really
special or exceptional about the um
approaches we take they're they're the
ones that are used by most
um labs i guess you know you're probably
your baseline cost is independent you
know it depends our assay is expensive
the
reagents are expensive and it's very
time consuming because it's a
kind of a first generation ngs assay
so that may your cost savings may be
less if your existing assay is more
efficient
but the genexis is very standardized
in terms of its cost all right thank you
very much for your answer i think uh our
audience will appreciate uh there's a
second question also for you
and this is about the t790m mutation
pretty typical resistance mutation of
egfr
and people are used to detect these when
they do a follow-up
liquid biopsy after for example i made
the first analysis on the on the on the
primary tumor
eventually uh so in in in your
experience so to say how useful would it
be the ability to use the same panel
in in tissue and liquid biopsy because
that's what the precision
assay is made for uh basically to be
used in both kind of
of tissue do you see this as a big
advantage or it's just a nice add-on
yeah i think that's an advantage you
know i think like with the newer drugs
that are being used for
egfr testing um coming out
the the need to identify t790m is
changing so you really the more that you
can detect
um from blood the more spectrum of
mutations you can detect the better
and also also too and sometimes and this
is maybe talking
uh you know a translational research
level maybe even getting to the clinical
level which might be outside the scope
of this talk
but um some some patients you can't get
another biopsy that you're limited so
blood's the only thing you do have to
work with so
by having a broader panel that's very
helpful so i do think that the more you
can do with a blood
based biopsy the better for your
research and the better for
translational medicine thank you very
much again appreciate it and now we have
a question for
for jane uh also for you thank you very
much for for your very informative
presentation
um first question is about the
comparison that you have shown between
the uncommand compressive v3
and the plus um the question is about
the
input material that you have used have
you
i i guess the answer is yes but this is
the question coming in
uh you used exactly the same input for
both essays
or the s or the input was different
no we use exactly the same input in fact
we use the same aliquot
of dna and they would only be uh
different in the in the in terms of time
so there would have been maybe you know
for those who want to get really
technical
one freeze thaw cycle you know between
the
oncoming v3 and the plus assay so they
were exactly the same
extraction the same aliquot just
different times
all right appreciate your answer there's
one more question for you
um it's a follow-up question around this
and
it's again on on the oncoming
comprehensive plus in this case you
you have shown the ability to detect
copy number variant
uh the question is actually is a little
bit uh straightforward so to say are
also a little bit um
i'll just say pro provocative in a way
yeah is this really useful in the
routine testing setting having copy
number
variants yeah i think um
you know i think it could help uh round
out
that you know complete understanding of
of the whole cancer it really depends on
the context that you're you're looking
you know at this cancer for us in the
translational research space
sometimes you want to get an idea of
what the rest of the genome is
is looking like relative to your you
know the variance that you're picking up
for the copy numbers that you're picking
up
um you know i go back you know for me
it's really interesting to be able to
see the genome because i go back to my
roots of cytogenetics then
and all that kind of stuff so i'd like
to see what else is going on in the
genome and not really hone in on the
particular
you know the diagnostically important
um copy number changes you know like do
or make or something like that i'd like
to see the whole thing so i feel like
the there is value and having the
ability to see that whole genome
all right appreciate that uh we have one
more question for craig
and uh this is actually about the
ability to detect rna fusion
uh how do you see let's say this
evolving
and and please uh change refer to to
to charming as well uh how do you see
the evolution
let's say between uh fish a detection of
fusion and ngs
do you see a switch more into the
direction of
ngs or do you see this fish still
uh you know it has to be used as a
orthogonal method for confirmation are
we moving away
from uh morphology based uh
testing in this case an optologist won't
be very happy to hear this i'm never
gonna say it again
but again how do you think this is gonna
this is gonna rule up in the future
that's a great question and especially
we have a cytogenesis here so it'll be
interesting
um we we've done we've run fish and have
transitioned over to the ngs based
platform and i think there's
a couple of advantages one ngs can be
more sensitive especially on small
samples
and sometimes you have samples and you
can use for example soft tissue tumors
where you really don't know what the
diagnosis
is so the fish is being less of a
confirmation study and more of a
diagnostic
tool to help you identify what the
entity is and you can do
fish ngs assays where
you can detect uh obscure fusion
partners too so i
i think that it's nice to get away from
fish it uses up a lot of tissue
it's very technically challenging um
depends on how good your lab is how good
your
cytogeneticists are at making difficult
calls
and it's a very powerful approach so i
think i mean if anything it it
truly complements it and is a is a real
workhorse in the lab
all right appreciate that jane not sure
if you want to add anything on that
no i completely agree i think there are
you know there are
definitely some advantages to the ngs
approach and
um you know there there is value in in
fish but i think uh it is really more in
the context of looking at the spatial
relationship you know looking at things
that are really more in the research
field like the spatial heterogeneity of
these fusions for example but if the
point is to detect the fusion
or detect these rearrangements then ngs
is really the way to go
all right yeah we have actually one last
question which is again for jane but
craig i would appreciate also you if you
wanna if you wanna uh um
charming so the the question is about if
you had experience
uh in sending out samples uh for you
know
uh for to provider for example you know
send outs
and what is the difference in the
success rate between
your in-house testing which actually
jane you have shown to be really high
and your send out the experience
um actually i'm gonna have to say that
we
um we've been doing all of our
sequencing you know in-house um
we've had we've actually had some people
send their samples to us to do
validation
you know so i think uh you know and it
goes both ways we found
we found um variants that weren't
detected through
other sequencing uh modalities and again
i think it speaks to the depth this is a
targeted panel so you're getting
you know explicit depth um you know in
these targeted panels that you just
don't get
from um say whole genome
so i think there's that sensitivity
there so um
we don't send a whole lot out actually
anymore
perfect
craig i don't know if you had any
experience in that
yeah um you know i think that um
usually you know with most
straightforward cases the
there's a high level of agreement with
send out and what we do in-house
where you can run into some differences
i think would be um
you know for variants that are difficult
to detect like if the
if the depth is much higher in one assay
or another that helps
but really another thing too is variants
can sometimes be annotated differently
on different pipelines from different
labs and that can sometimes cause
confusion
it's the same variant it's just
described differently
and i've noticed that occasionally
happens
all right appreciate your your uh your
answer
so now i want to thank you both for for
your presentation but also for taking
the time to
to answer to this question and i also
want to close this session
uh again thank you very much for joining
also thanks to the audience for uh for
being with us
and uh it's not the end of the entire
event there's still
uh something to go for and it's the demo
presentation
live of the gen xs from our laboratories
in california
uh my colleague andrew is gonna do that
and
also i would like to remind you that
that the entire environment stays open
so if you have the opportunity please
visit the whole of poster there's a lot
of nice
fresh data out there that might help you
and it has been a pleasure to moderate
this event uh
thank you all very much again see you
next time